all right and we are live and the last
word is live is what is going on man we
have been away what's going on sir uh
well we have had holidays and New Year's
and crazy things have happened in the
world of destiny
and outside of the world of destiny on a
real life things have happened
we've had some deliberations mostly you
wanting to strangle me about a main
story that's fair
I'm a really picky person I don't like
to uh takes me a while to decide on
things so like trust me it's one of
those the person who helped design my
logo would probably agree and probably
want to strangle me as well so should we
find you're not alone uh but yeah
welcome guys this is the podcast of a
new name so if you guys are tuning in
live you guys make it the will switch
over we've got a lot to talk about
coming up we're gonna discuss everything
with Bungie and Activision just kind of
our thoughts on it just kind of the post
that they made just kind of the feeling
in the community and then we'll get to
everything that kind of happened
recently this week as we got new content
kind of in a sense we eventually got
some content and then this week at
Bungie we've been waiting to do this for
that one to come out and that piece is
gonna be both of us looking at it live
so we actually don't even know what's in
there yet you may have peaked but mostly
we're gonna kind of give some reactions
as we go through that so you guys
strapped in it's gonna be a long one and
first piece podcast name so some of you
guys may have wondered why we were
looking at changing the name and if you
want to cover this one also you might
know it better it's like there was there
was basically another one but it was
like another like gaming podcast
basically correct yeah basically they
were eSports entity yeah that's right
yeah so um I'm gonna jump off you got
the first word shouts Lola chase that I
like the new name zero very fitting
thank you sir thank you sir
uh he said I prefer crystal meth the
game but this is [ __ ] I don't understand
slow-mo you're just you're just rolling
us now hello slow that's what I do right
yeah man um you know so here's the thing
I mean it's one of those things where
you know you don't want to step one toes
obvious you want to be respectful of
people in your same space and it
basically came down to again nothing
happened to us there was no cease and
desist sent from them to us it was just
something I kind of browsed in court and
said oh interesting and uh obviously
they're gonna be at Guardian con and I'd
like to we could we could introduce
ourselves as the last word to know now
hood oh yeah it'll be cool but
ultimately it was one of those things
when we just wanted to create that
separation in the Destiny space and you
know through a lot of deliberation you
know this was one of the finest we had
some great suggestions some hilarious
suggestions obviously and from your base
as well he like oh my god some of the
some of the suggestions were like
outstanding so and funny yeah so this
one that kind of came to it kind of kind
of fit you know since so um you know
obviously we like to get the last word
on a lot of topics and um you know the
first word on a lot of topics as well
and you know it's for me personally
obviously the gun has it's near and dear
to me and it's kind of one of my first
exotics and the story behind it is
pretty cool you know for destiny guys
you know you guys know it immediately
when you see that name so that was one
of the things that one to resonate as
well as not using something like
Guardian destiny podcast that's what I
got but one thing I will well a stay for
a passive actor is that only good during
this process I learned that my man II is
he's the true definition of an artist
like he it's a particular person every
big has half the purpose it's very
specific and though it's cool getting to
collaborate and then I kind of go back
and forth you know say because you get
you learn stuff about your friend and
one thing I learned about him he is a
perfectionist he works very hard glad to
do this podcast with him even though
sometimes I do what a triangle him do
but I'm glad we came down to the last
word yeah you guys probably seen some of
the Twitter polls some of the things
that we're out there we had narrowed it
down to a couple long point was honestly
just Canada
joke so I mean you guys have been with
us long enough some of you guys some of
you guys may be new to the podcast but
really it's like flashpoint you know
it's the tease of destiny of course it's
like but everything we do ends up being
ridiculously long so it never was like
this brief hey this little 15-minute
discussion we usually fall into like two
hours and we're not even close to the
word flash so the joke was out there
there were some mothers but the last
word I mean as you said it's like it's
fitting it was like one of the first
ones that I saw of all the suggestions
that some of you guys came up with just
just like struck a chord with me and it
was just like it fits because we are a
podcast like the wording it's still
generic so if you want to talk about
some other stuff as well so if other
games coming up in the future are part
of the discussion then you know we're
not exactly tied in but if you guys
appreciate destiny then it's you know a
nice deep cut and coming up a recent one
so all of the good things are happening
so so what we settled on and I would say
we're pretty happy where we're at and I
think hopefully you guys enjoy it as
well so that's quick introduction out of
the way if nothing else you guys get to
deal with us for a little while so I say
a little while but as you guys know the
last word is going to be about two hours
from now probably because this is gonna
be a long one we have a lot of stuff to
discuss yeah so intro out of the way I'm
just gonna let you open this one up to
get started because we had some insane
news drop yesterday and if you haven't
heard it yet I'm gonna let kognito tell
you what happened man own this is
probably destiny is a very polarizing
game and as long as I've been a fan of
it and then covering it it is always in
the middle of something and boy this
week we've got a Megaton I mean if
there's no other way to describe it it's
just something that when the news feed
crossed my phone they shout out the Lord
King is probably one of the first to
come prey to my attention and um you
know you just seen that headline anyway
just read you know Bungie splits from
Activision and you're like I cannot
believe this like how did this happen
right
we get here what's going on it's it's
it's truly one of those things that I
wouldn't never I couldn't predict
happening you know I'm saying if we had
to stop he's gonna go and yeah a lot of
thoughts came to my head you know um it
was kind of fitting like I said this
mega news kind of started once we wanted
to debut the you know the new name for
the show and we definitely get the last
word on this one but oh man but yeah
like let's just talk about the emotional
aspect like when you first saw bungee
splits from Activision what was the
first thing that went through your mind
it's hard to narrow it down there was so
much stuff I mean mine was B it's
there's a lot of feelings out there in
the community and then you look a little
bit deeper rumors of what happened in
boardrooms and things like that and
we'll get to those in a little bit but
generally it was just the fact that I
think it's more that I kind of I I'm
hoping this is the final step that lets
destiny gets where we all have kind of
wanted it to get to from the beginning
mm-hmm as you said destiny is a game of
it's a divisive game people love it
people hated people like get to like
times where like oh I can't stand this
game okay I played it for a hundred
hours but I can't stay in this game
you're like like people say that stuff
all the time be like how I played this
game 500 hours but it's so poor you're
like why are you still playing it like
that stuff happens all the time with you
because it has one of those weird
natures but it's also one of those
things that everybody's like always like
blaming Activision blame inactive and
it's like and I think it was like Fran
or pyro it's like I've seen in a couple
places it's like Activision is one of
the ones that put a giant bankroll
behind Bungie to help take a large
investment in kind of a risk yes this
was a big property this was a long-term
I mean you know though mention of a
10-year contract so all of these things
of like you know Activision Stephanie
one of my first things was like I'm on
PC what's gonna happen about on that
like and they have confirmed that that's
gonna be fine so I think that's gonna be
there that's just a platform they're on
but yeah it's like everybody's always
like blame Activision blame Activision
it's
there are bounces like their business
you know they stop stockholders they
still have earnings things in all those
pieces it's all of those little things
coming together and now it's all the
earnest is on bungee lake it is
literally in their hands to make or
break this game to be what all the fans
want it to be or to you know maybe take
it or not everybody wants to and all we
can do is at this point sit back and
wait yeah yeah I mean you nailed it I
think for me it was one of those things
it's a from the emotional aspect it's a
two-part thing for me the first part is
you feel elation you feel happy we do
know that there were conflicts we do
know that you know the relationship had
restraining on Munchie right I'm not
gonna sit here and paint evil Activision
all day that's not what I want to do but
at the same thing we have to be real
about the relationship it's just like
anything you know it people go through
ups and downs so that was the first
thing the other part of me is even
though I do have that happiness it's
that fear of the unknown
because regardless to how you feel about
Activision and they have their
reputation and it's warranted for
certain for certain things you know we
always say like we watch a new destiny
trailer like man that marketing man
those visuals right so yep this kind of
thing just makes me that the part that I
was just concerned about it's like going
forward now that everything is on Bungie
and we have to be honest like Bungie
definitely has made their own share of
mistakes themselves that everything is
Activision's fault so it's just you know
going forward right like let's see how
they handle things and you know not at
everything's on them we we know first
that table was really late today but we
ain't gonna get into I was like yeah
there's a reason it was late cuz this
had yesterday I know I got I got a
teaser so like that we waited 12
feverishly read you and we like it's
about my I want to make each other like
during the Activision era this this
definitely snap we should get our 12s on
time is it joke I was like n0 said in
chat it's like the scapegoat is gone
everybody can be like aw Bungie this
it's like cult Activision's false
Activision's fault and it's also one of
those pieces like Activision still puts
out
I mean a lot of games they are a large
publisher they've got wizard and stuff
it's like what and as you said whatever
you think about what's going on it's to
the point of like their Arden there is
no one else to blame whether you know if
bunch you made the ever verse and they
keep it around but it's like honestly
like ever verse is in an okay spot even
if it stays late you know is this all my
trick microtransactions like guess what
guys they're technically one of the
bigger indie studios in the world now
they have to make their own money things
like that are probably gonna happen so
those little things that people are
people just saying are you gonna get rid
of ever sorry what are we gonna do is
there gonna be a subscription nobody has
any idea the plan of what is currently
out there for the seasons is gonna stay
III whatever is gonna be announced for
September is going to be a very giant
tell because yes probably the biggest
question mark we know what's going
through your what is this year five we
know how year five looks at this point
we pretty much know most of it except
season or redacted your six could be
anything honestly I mean it could be
they have something plan they're working
on it it could be hey we've got this
content guys we you know we'll try and
get some other seasonal stuff out with
the live team but we're really not gonna
do anything major for another year
because we really are waiting for the
next generation of consoles destiny
three is gonna be its thing in 2020 I
mean that could be their choice because
they literally can make that choice
they're just gonna have to see other
community reacts but at least they get
to make the choice yes and people are
gonna love or hate it but at least we
know it's them 100% punchy we know where
the buck stops at this point absolutely
do you want to get into the mission
statement that was released yesterday
you want to transition into that or no
we got it right here so I'm gonna just
read it yeah let's go for it alright so
when I first launched our partnership
with Activision in 2010 the gaming
industry was a pretty different place as
an independent studio setting out to
build a brand new experience we wanted a
partner willing to take a big leap of
faith we literally said that already we
had a vision for destiny that we
believed in but to launch a game of that
magnitude we needed the support of an
established publishing partner with
Activision we created something special
to date destiny has delivered a combined
over 50 million games and expansions to
players around the world more
importantly we've also witnessed the
remarkable
community tens of millions of Guardians
strong rise up and embrace destiny to
play together to make and share memories
and even to do truly great things that
reach far beyond the game we share to
deliver a positive impact on people's
everyday lives I was like there's more
to it but I almost say I don't even need
to read much more than you want me to
finish it your whole thing no I mean you
can skip pass I mean I just pretty much
wanted to say you know I'll go into that
paragraph really the plan transition is
already underway its annexed ages with
Bungie and Activision both committed to
make sure the handoff is as seamless as
possible but Forsaken we listen learn
and what we believe our players want
from a great destiny experience that
sentence is very key I'm gonna get into
that and rest assured there's more on
the way we'll continue to deliver on the
existing destiny roadmap we're looking
forward to releasing more seasonal
experiences in the coming months as well
as our surprise icon communing with some
exciting announcement about what lies
beyond then the rest is kind of like a
thank you yadda yadda yadda
you know um two things to me when I see
stuff like this and um you know when
that sentence you know obviously would
forsaken and we know the history you
know we remember that infamous you know
conference call our earnings call by
Activision during you know post forsaken
launch and how you know they voice their
displeasure their voice their
displeasure of the sales you know that
it wasn't as performing up to what they
you know expect it and you know that's
fine that's their investment they're
allowed to say what they have to say but
at the same time we do know the
community felt away because we all felt
forsaken was to take in King moment on a
greater scale right yep we all felt you
know that was such an amazing piece of
content this is the Bungie we want this
is the game we want this the destiny one
but if you remember II I'll never forget
it's always in the back of our mind is
Luke Smith oh I was like if you didn't
say it I was about to say oh when he put
that tweet out in response to that
Activision earnings call to me it
signified dysfunction between those two
his balls eNOS to go up against and bury
your boss you're basically challenging
your boss hold your you know hold you
hey I don't agree with you we we believe
in what we're doing we don't think that
this is a disappointment right so when
you've got the creator and then you know
the creators guys and the money guys
kind of going at it you know to me that
just signifies something greater but I
always commended because let's be honest
it easy to go against your boss when
that check coming yeah it's like it's a
big and I think that's the one thing
everybody's like hey it's so awesome you
guys completely on their own and that is
awesome but honestly like some people
have to remember this is a big risk yes
and that's one of the things people have
to try and keep in consideration if
they're thinking hey you guys are
awesome it's like so cool so many good
things are coming it's like it's like if
you thought those guys work their tails
off before now there's literally nobody
backing them up with like the Activision
funds to say hey you guys need another
year to develop this where's it gonna
come from now it's like those little
pieces are the considerations that need
to need to be to help our expectations
stay in check if they like if they say
hey we want this content coming out in
September but it's not gonna be ready
we're gonna push it till March or
something if they start to make those
type of calls the community hopefully
will roll with them I'm crossing my
fingers but a destiny community is so
two-sided you never know exactly and
you're making great point see because at
the end of the day one thing we know we
can assume that is that the content
release schedule of an Activision is
they keep wanting you to pump this stuff
out what timed basis and we know for you
know we know for a fact that a lot of
times destiny would and Bungie we're not
able to release all in these windows and
a lot of things got pushed back then we
actually we change the format right we
went from the big DLC kind of thing the
DLC content structure to now annual pass
structure so it's one of those things
now it's like being that it's now all on
Bungie what happens now moving forward
with the content structure also
separating from Activision let's be
honest like you know we did find out
that a battlenet is gonna be okay
but you know all that stuff is under the
Activision umbrella so at some point
there is gonna be a transition right
there is gonna be what's gonna does it
go to steam there's a lot of question
don't go to epic cuz that's it shine
Blair who just got division - Oh Zane it
was a huge change huge huge huge you so
it is it it the competition is fierce
out there and let's be honest I mean you
know Activision also brought in with
Vicarious Visions high Moon Studios to
help Bungie out with a lot of things so
you know that supports not gonna be
there but in the bungees defense they've
got that investor I believe um I've got
a Nettie's I've got the name of them no
it's not right oh yes the mobile thing
mobile you know they've got their
independence what happens to PlayStation
exclusivity that's another piece right
is that base to Activision is that base
to Sony just actually and destiny is
there like a contract there does the
contract fall apart if this falls apart
right if it's lost play cross say not
easy and they don't even walk I'm not
really concerned about cross plate while
it would be cool
cross save has got to be one that is
like I want and if this helps with that
didn't tell ya like hopefully those
little pieces and but I don't think
they're gonna happen that soon yeah
that's what I was like if it's you know
September if it's 2024 destiny 3 those
little pieces are things that hopefully
now doors can be opened so yes and those
are things you definitely look for and I
want to shout out a shout to a lord
Richard hull gov Hogan law he's got a
great piece right now please check it
out it's um if you check out hold law
his youtube channel h OE g l aw he's got
a series called virtual legality this
guy is a corporate lawyer he understands
contract he's been in the industry for a
bunch of years and the way he broke that
whole situation down you know as far as
the separation and the transition and
one thing we've got a sale to before I
get into that is that both of them were
respectful on the split oh yeah they
were
yeah I've seen splits you know not go so
good and you know people talk so it was
an amicable thing even Activision put
out a statement you know hey Guardians
you know wish you guys the best that
kind of deal you know
at the end of the day you know you
didn't burn any more bridges you know
it's it's a it's a clean break and now
we got to see what's going on but in
reference to the contract you know it's
definitely going to be interesting
because we do 4 minus 10 and again shout
the whole law you know that is the Sony
exclusivity so that's all part of the
Activision situation and therefore their
fulfillment from my understanding coke
is that um there was for destiny games
they had to produce you know so far they
produced two and then for quote-unquote
comet DLCs the common DLCs would be
considered like two taking Kings the
Forsaken and again they committed to two
so basically not a disarrangement the
way is explained to me is that bounty
this arrangement is has ended has been
terminated and most likely amended to
allow them to release because clearly
Activision has some dissatisfaction with
um you know their in their investment
quote-unquote Bungie the game and what
they felt it should be performing so now
it comes down to what are the terms
how long does Bungie kind of go into
this state of because it even though
it's a clip it's a break it's according
to way it's explained legally they just
can't make okay new can't like super
content different starting now you don't
like they still have to follow that road
map that was introduced Michael what do
a DJ's tweet said I'm over okay gonna
follow this this is going on so I get I
think the earliest you know we'll see
something you know is post and you'll
pass like that next quote-unquote comet
which would be September yep that will
tell us a lot
you know what do you think II I mean
yeah I think we're pretty much on the
same page there we've got you know the
season that's planned out season
directed and then yeah it's like
September is the September is what is
unannounced right and I think this is a
good time for them to get ahead give
them time to plan for e3 work through
the season see how it feels see how
they're doing how the money's flowing
give them a little time but I'm like
there are ready they already know what
they're working on they know it's
planned and it's just gonna wait and see
what's announced and how it's delivered
so the big the big tell is gonna be like
first is it September I think that's
gonna be the first test is do they
actually hold their feet to the fire
hey we're always gonna be that September
title or they're like you know what
that's knees still destiny we're gonna
be flexible I mean they have like the
years so I mean they've been on this
sequence for a while but they finally
have potentially some freedom to turn
around and say you know it's like we
could have a season but there's
something in there's a chance for them
to say we mean we don't have we it's
like I don't know how else they say it
besides like we love giving as the
content we can but we want to put a
little more time into these pieces of
content so they may be farther apart and
then that's where you go back to the gap
so it's like some people are gonna be
wondering is the push of Activision who
continually tries to give us content we
had the gaps they've tried to go to the
Annual Pass you know their thoughts
about that we'll be curious to see if
that's something they try again as well
because they may not even wanted to an
annual pass maybe that was an Activision
thing maybe that was them in how they
want to deliver the content I don't know
like there's so many questions and I
think whatever as you said September
whether it's 2020
whether it's dusty 3 whether they take a
break and just go full force on it or
they they have a small life stuff that
keeps going I have no freaking clue I
react me give you last word or something
else what about do you think let's keep
a person with you let's say now as a
result of the Activision separation that
that now changes the content frequency
so let's just say now that there's more
of a gap but it's more of what Bungie
wants to do you know how do you feel
about that again I'm assuming they
everything could still maintain the same
I'm just giving you a scenario that
let's just say content takes a little
longer right you know what hey you know
you get that drop and it's a hopefully
it's a quality drop are you okay with
that or do you kind of are you used to
that cadence that we normally would get
you know you get the September release
and then usually around December or
whatever you get like another little
mini release something like that it's
like where you at with the content
breakdown I mean as we've it's something
we've grown accustomed to and of course
this player base is finicky as all
get-out most of the time I mean they are
third it's like they know what they want
they
can never have enough content so if
there's a bigger gap they're gonna get
some hell but also if Bungie is like if
they're gonna be happy putting out a
next piece of content that's like
forsaken times to whatever d3 or
September whatever you know destiny film
like like whatever that ends up being is
what I'm excited for
so as I've said before it's like
honestly there's so much time and trying
to keep up with destiny if I ever get a
break I might get to catch up on some
other games because seriously it's
sometimes it's trying to do this all the
time stay up I was like we got January
and February it's like I got two
characters up to 650 the third one
probably won't take us long finishing up
the four words we'll do the last request
we'll have some down time in February
other games like anthem and division are
gonna hit right at the time of gambit
mm-hmm and it's like there probably is
gonna be some breaks in there and
changes so it's like there's going to be
other things and it's them hopefully
having the flexibility to decide when
they want to release do they I mean
September is not a bad month for them
because it is all the before the
insanity of October he still kind of
gets in towards that holiday timeframe
when people are getting back into a
routine and stuff like that
summers getting back in so I mean that's
one of those pieces if they want to
still fight for that slot I mean it's
it's tough it's just interesting I mean
it's it like I said there's like a the
the future you know it's it's a so many
unknowns like you don't know what's
gonna happen and it's it's exciting yet
it's scary at the same time like I just
hope like they have their ducks in a row
they know exactly what they want to do
the game they want to do you know don't
make a whole bunch of rash decisions but
at the same time one good sign is by
them constantly referencing forsaking as
in that statement that they learned they
listened you know remember another key
point I'll never forget you know during
you know the the early flashpoint era is
you know that infamous Bungie meeting
with the content creators right yeah
Rick brought us there for everyone in
the community that had a voice for the
most part in all different aspects of
the game pvp lore the whole bit and um
you know to see them
bring that in and then make that
changing and forsaken be what it is and
them proud of forsaking gives me
confidence that they realize that's the
Destiny we want right you know so it's
good let's let's see let's just see if
they could fulfill on the promise let's
see what happens with the content also
the next generation you know what you
know we transition transition into that
a little bit after as far as what
happens with degree lighting stuff of
cross play and cross progression I'm
with you II I think it's only a matter
of time with um cross progression at
least you know I'm saying I think that I
mean hopefully you know I think it's
it's the natural evolution of the series
you know again what's gonna happen when
microtransactions tests you know I
forgot whose article iris or you know
someone's like they're gonna do a
cinematic and just blow up everything I
doubt that's a Bigfoot alright it's one
of those things where it's like you know
microtransaction still memories it
remained in the game you know so we have
to temper our expectations with that I
mean they still need to Bungie needs to
make money so you know it's it's it's
exciting it's new it's scary
but man what like a news bombshell this
week like this was completely unexpected
yeah I mean to wrap up most of what you
said 2018 for our podcast was started at
probably one of the lowest points we've
ended at one of the craziest points not
ended but we've like wrapped up the year
with the forges and forsaken and a
year's worth of changes and they patched
the game like 25 times or something like
that all the things that Bungie has done
and worked towards and they are happy
with well it's not a perfect game it is
moving in a really good direction and
there are things that hopefully they
keep listening to feedback and we'll get
to community feedback here in a little
bit but it's it's a lot of things going
in a good direction like forsaken the
new supers the sartorial like dreaming
city a dungeon was like a new thing and
that was freaking amazing I still love
that all those little pieces have been
showing us what they I think they want
to do and I'm hoping more of that stuff
comes and for me when the game is at its
highest even if it's like in like you
know figuring out how to balance
something like an annual pass where
there will get to that kind of
discussion whether it's delaying or
release so they have the content or the
story how they want it to be because
they might have either backing somewhere
else or they're finally independent
enough they can do that if all of those
things finally start coming together I
think it's just something to be
cautiously optimistic because as you
said there's a lot of questions but I
was like I've liked what's happened in
the past year and I look forward to the
future absolutely man absolutely so so
what do we have yeah I was gonna say so
that pretty much covers that and it's
like there are what's up Rick how you
doing there's there's gonna be talked
about this for a while we won't know
much that's gonna happen for a while
because even DJ's tweet was like we're
not gonna talk about the side of the
business for awhile they're pretty much
just gonna focus on the content they've
got so this is pretty much all we're
gonna know probably around III is when
we're gonna start to get our first
glimmers or science or whatever you know
the future of content will hold so we'll
wait until that happens so for now let's
talk about what's actually been
happening and we've got some forge
action going on whoo so if you guys
haven't painted since of the world the
destiny which I'm sure you have if
you're what listened to are two crazy
people heads so we had Niobe Labs lunch
mm-hmm
now Niobe labs is what was supposed to
be the gateway per se to the final forge
the burgoo Zia Forge
we've noticed that kind of got to the
final piece of a quest we've got another
gun dropping now all these things have
been starting to happen but there was a
pretty substantial wall before we got
there so I want to get your thoughts
first on Niobe labs launch and then just
generally how you felt the forges have
been thus as far as you know content
it's been about a month so yeah about a
month obviously um you know it's one of
those things where you know I see what
they're trying to do as far as a foot
obviously took me a while to get up to
level you know and to be honest it felt
more of a DPS check than
anything else but once I started doing
the activity you know shout out shout to
you bro Stone Fox help me out yeah there
you go you know you know yeah I got
going in there it's got the activity
started and messing around and seeing
what kind of the end game represents so
you know it's it's a cool time out it's
a cool activity the thing now where we
we now break it down to okay you gotta
lock it for you're gonna lock that for
is okay cool
now we get to the big o switch is the
big one this is the one now you got to
do this puzzle we got to find out what's
going on with labs and all this stuff
and I just thought it was hilarious
because no one configured this like it
was so hardcore like the people out
there like the tweets will a shout the
more console absolutely hilarious people
with the means and the gifs and the the
third eye open and trying to put all
these things together on a board and it
would you know somebody was like I think
was one guy he's like what what are we
doing what has this game just like every
movie scene where you see crazy
number-crunching going on his ex what
was going on for 24 hours basically
between dad oh and glad and as I'll say
no to rages in the mix and you had their
little their groups like working on it
like 20,000 people watching and it's
it's one of those things where Blake it
was popular on Twitch but you're like at
what expense so you can continue it stop
teasing me about gif I always say I
don't get Killer Bee the cherry wood
ones the peanut butter ones in animated
pictures Oh anyway oh yeah you got you
got yeah I got the last word on gif so
yeah man like basically it just came
down to you know thing being very
difficult but I'm torn because I think
if we had this discussion in discord
would scream and part of me kind of
likes that nobody was able to figure it
out and the community was trying to come
together to you know see what this you
know big puzzle was gonna lead and all
these different things you know so that
part about is cool you know as far as
why
not being able to figure out in time
beaten the content that's where it gets
a little dicey that's what that's what I
want your opinion on okay little
long-winded look long-winded intro now
let's see what you think about okay you
log in on Tuesday like my brother and
he's like alright so how do we start
this next forge and I was like you can't
what what do you think what do you think
of that people logging in on the 8th and
being like all right so who do I have to
go kill to kick off my next quest to get
my next frame what wait
yeah like yeah any problem big problem
and you're right and that that to me is
where they falter it should not have
been the barrier for entry and I believe
tasks use an example that I agree with
which is like it's the equivalent of
doing the outbreak having to solve the
outbreak prime quests before you can do
the wrath of machine raid so that is a
mistake and again the thought the heart
was in the right place as far as doing
something difficult and challenging but
you know not to you can't block people
from playing new content so that's where
I agree with you and you bro but what
what do you feel what do you feel like
yeah I mean it's like the puzzles are
ridiculous I got in there I got home
here to play with a couple people and we
were working on it's trying to figure
out watching people's twitch like
getting in the raid to Secrets discord
seeing what was going on they kept like
catching pieces and figure it out and
people are like going back and re
watching because I don't know if
somebody did it on accident for one of
the phases and they were like it was
just like standing here and then they
figured it out there's you can't solo it
by the way there's one of the levels
that you actually have to shoot three
things at the same exact time so you get
to a point you can't solo it Wow
so there's different pieces with like
different symbols in different codes
that you do someone backwards orders the
codes were like kind of just randomly
obscure like some of the ways some of us
figured out somebody was just like
hailed try the word like some of you got
I'm sorry if I spoil it for you but one
of the first ones is like butterfly what
the like text was like in French
somebody who knew French like translated
it's like did you get Chad and it was
like for those who seek knowledge it
it's like you have to live in the dark
or something like that I keep messing up
the truth about what it means but it's
something like that then all of a sudden
it's like butterfly and I'm going what
how is that connection even close so
some of them were like such huge
stretches some of them made sense like
they were like maps and connections but
they were so so crazy
and so while the puzzles themselves were
cool as you said it did not need to be
what stopped just getting into the forge
yeah now what I would have liked this to
have been it has been like hey so you
finish up the forge and then you know
but you don't get kicked to orbit then
you just like and all of a sudden you
just finish the foreword you get the
boss you get your drops and you just
still staying in there and people start
looking around and then they say they
find like a tunnel and then they fall
into like Niobe labs and then they find
this and they're like looking around see
this kind of like just you know armory
type structure or what I mean however
you want to look at it and then somebody
like pulls out one of the rifles because
they've seen it before and they find one
of these symbols there oh crap like so
you like yeah you got to go finish the
Forge and they can go roaming around
there and sit there for a while then
like start doing that and if that
unlocks like and unfortunately what it's
worth also is not enough to my baby
because now I get out for you what what
break break break break down with I I
don't know if you just get like an
emblem and a ghost or something like
that like it's I think that's all they
said in the - in the tweet no it's not
been solved yet maybe there's more I
don't know but that insanity for just
that type of cosmetic stuff sucks to me
it's not nearly enough for the work that
these people put in the people of
vicarious visions who were sitting back
on Twitter like one guy with the peach
on his need he's just sitting there
watching and they're doing like one of
those raid things but they're watching
just beat their heads against puzzles
because like you get to like level six
easily and stay there and try it over
and over if you if you don't get it
right you get killed you start a whole
six level run over and then you got to
try it again so every attempt as they
got farther into the levels kept getting
farther and and like every attempt kept
getting farther between
so you get to like level five and be
like okay now we got to do like a
ten-minute sequence of fights just to
try this nope okay why let's you know
take the pictures there to look at
twitch and for low okay let's try this
nope and then you got to level six it's
like okay now it's a 12-minute fight now
it's like a 15-minute fight just for
them to keep getting an attempt at like
even if they think they have it just to
make a chance there was no checkpoints
nothing like
all for two tokens in a blue interesting
but for me what I would want love to
have this to have done is if say hey
they went through the black armory they
went through all this crazy puzzle and
just like me like hey they're working on
getting it solved you know they're
working on like an orbital printing dad
was doing is like you know binary
translation and stuff like that all of a
sudden they do that and they need like
something like a dungeon opens and we'd
be like holy and that opens for the
community that would be the point where
I'd be like hell yes and that would be
the proper sequence of events in my
opinion because it needs to if you're
gonna go through that much insanity
there better be something really amazing
behind it because it's I'm saying that's
and that was my big issue was wrist like
the effort versus the reward isn't even
close and then just locking out what you
promised us for content saying hey Niobe
Labs is a puzzle you didn't say it's
like a crook Tut like a NASA
cryptographers late I'm sorry that's a
mapmaker
Vanessa a NASA codebreakers like puzzle
challenge for the day or something like
that
like we're not rocket scientist guys I
mean they were going for like French
words and like Japanese and you had like
Norse words for trees and forests and
every different spelling I'm like
they're making some crap up it's insane
so like the theory behind it was cool
but it needed to unlock something like
shattered thrown in my bag it was I
think yeah I think like I said the
thought was great I don't mind secrets I
don't mind a community coming together
it's just the execution you know it
shouldn't lock content like you said and
you know the reward better be something
amazing you know say at least you know
when you get all that stuff when we got
outbreak prime you know that we were
like okay you know I mean like this is
solid it had great DPS it was good
against bosses was gonna get single
targets you know me ads and stuff like
that so um you know I'm good showing
that you know I guess the last question
I haven't if we move on with the what
that Forge is um what do you feel behind
the decision making of Bungie to say
okay you know you guys they figure it
out
we're lack of it like what did you feel
when you would you could you know that
well I can say glad and daddo probably
felt like I got slapped in the face and
sure glad has a tweet out there that I
can't even repeat mm-hmm like his word
choice ty litter I'm not gonna say it up
so for them it's like a slap in the face
unfortunately because they spent all
that time and then they're like oh I
guess it's too long we did something too
hard so we're gonna give you the content
anyway so for them it's a really tough
learning experience unfortunately and
it's like the streamers are crazy I mean
if you go look at like the stats like
glad posted about that stream like I
mean it worked in his benefit even if he
did you know probably break his sleep
cycle for about two days but I mean they
had they brought the caming community
together but then unfortunately some
people are also like is this my brother
for example it's just like it's this
content in this like puzzle really meant
for just like you know six or 12 teams
on Twitch like is this just really on
Twitch 'man is that all it is Wow is
this like hey do you just want are you
just trying to like a raid release bump
up this puzzle-solving to raise bungee
up arrange dusty to rise it up on the
twitch starts playing and that's kind of
a weird question but it's like it's not
wrong because I mean wrong it was up
there in the top ten for a couple days
and it'll fall down and it'll go back to
kind of its you know a normal status but
that's kind of the issue is it's when
they they saw there was an issue I mean
I think it would have been better if
they would have liked tracted me like
okay and I think they gave one hint when
they were stuck on six Ferb I don't know
12 hours or some stupid amount they were
stuck on six for forever and I don't
think they've gave any hint given a hint
on seven and they needed to set
expectations I guess I think somebody I
think said Fred in chat was like did
they warn the community and they could
have been like hey we're gonna give you
guys 48 hours or it could have just been
like Niobe Labs is gonna go alive it
just said there there is a puzzle in
there it's a puzzle and just said that
burgoo xia Forge launches on Friday if
you guys finish this before Friday and
then you know burgoo xia forge will be
unlocked otherwise it launches on friday
if they would have said that the
expectation would have been different
i were setting expectations i think was
the other piece that they get the guy
they got wrong and
and I think that's what burned a lot of
people too because for my brother when
he looks at the calendar he sees an IB
Labs thinking it's like hey here's this
thing for another for is this gonna be
like a dungeon to a forge a little mini
encounter and then you get there and
then they can't even do anything
especially like you know solo player you
can't even matchmaking anything yeah it
was like what what do you do so yeah
setting expectations I think would have
helped a lot
I would agree man and that's it that was
the last word okay we're good you backed
it out the part you you a delay because
I mean literally does that all my
thoughts on it and I just want to get
your perspective definitely from someone
who was experiencing it was going
through it and I just thought it was
actually absolutely hilarious to see
people losing their brain trying to
figure out all these scientific
equations and puzzles it like I mean the
translations the like stuff they were
trying to figure out stand on this
symbol for morning and then I figured
out paper is also like missive which is
an old school word for a message it was
like well that learned something new so
all those little pieces were things that
it was interesting and they were kind of
pulling from the other forges and
symbols that we'd seen before man they
were like those were some stretch puzzle
like solutions they were absolutely out
there yeah it was cool for me to
actually be able to jump in with a
couple of the people and not get a full
raid team and actually kind of work on
it I like the three-person feel and that
was kind of cool but yeah expectations
was probably would have helped the whole
situation not have been quite the bottom
that it was agreed agreed oh well we got
I mean so yeah forges forges open and
then the other piece is like you know
niobe labs it's like you know this Forge
this words of this Forge the niobe labs
and they in there'd been little things
about their burgers eeeh forage about
lore and we're like hey is this at least
gonna open some cooler forage or like
the ultimate forage and from what I've
seen I haven't actually jumped in
because I'm finished in quest but from
what I've seen it's just another Forge
like I wish there would have been
something a little bit more either
mechanically different or something else
to this final one's a mechanic's is this
throwing being angry sure yeah like from
what I've got
it's I mean I looked around like you
mean I saw somebody you know shooting
the boss or my cliff I saw him like just
you know killing enemies throwing the
orbs in it it seems like it's still a
forge so mm-hmm
I mean that's where I'm torn because at
the end of the day it's like you know I
want I wanna like the concept of the
content but I just think that a lot of
stuff is stretched to be honest I feel a
lot of time getting stuff a lot of DPS
check stuff you know if each Forge had
like tremendously different mechanical
actually don't mind it actually played
the first one you know what actually you
can get into this it's because I like
the timer of it's like okay boom
intensity let's go let's go you know get
the ball store the thing
okay cool melter Porsha everything is on
time time time like that but if every if
you're telling me like every account is
kind of similar to that and there's
really no game playing differences oh
you know Sam so that that is where I
struggle I think each individual needs
to be very different from the other they
need to be unique to have that you don't
mean you know you don't kind of get
natty yeah it's like I wish they had
just a little bit more distinction to
them exactly exactly
mm-hmm so look at your phone by the way
yeah it's like it's been crazy the
fortunes have been interesting I know
some people enjoy the fact like hey I
want to grind for this said pulse rifle
for example I was going for blast
furnace and all my rules suck so that's
just still work in progress but for me I
think there's just a couple tweaks they
need to happen with the Forge themselves
and just all of kind of eight of one's
experiences as you've been going through
the quest as you work on your weapon
frames they really need to like adjust
the times we have to go to the tower I
know they gave us a new landing zone but
it's not like do these things go back to
the tower it's like just use voiceover
and the stuff would go a lot faster
like that's just one thing I do have to
like ask for it is because it's it's
just like it's not
necessary you're going through so much
work you're like doing steps you gotta
go back to go back talk to her get some
flavor text okay go do this okay go do
this trick okay go talk to her go do
that it's like it's not necessary if it
was just like hey there's a quest step
or you you know click on the quest and
then you know it has the voice over at
the end so it just has a longer ending
to whatever you're doing and you just
like use the voice over instead of
having to travel back and forth please
that's that's my one asked about the
forges yeah and then the grind would not
be bad the grind would be better
honestly if that was if that was the way
it could work
so that's lad to get that little tidbit
in there cuz I was grinding blast
furnace and you had to like if I could
just go kill the enemies with pulse
rifles don't get my radiance seeds and
then just go straight to the Forge and
like I kill the pulse rifles go here go
back to Ada go back do this do it again
like if it would just needs too much
back and forth it's not necessary
there's no need to make that extra quest
up in there it's not like I'm gonna go
by the tower and swing by ever verse and
you know spend some money it's like that
is not even crossing my mind especially
because you give him a landing zone
you're not even trying to do that it's
just it doesn't seem necessary so yeah I
agree I I hope that's a tweak that comes
sometime down the road because it
desperately needs to happen if these
things are gonna hang around I agree all
right get out of the way I think it's
time well we gotta get Bundy yes
and this is why I say if you guys see
the icon on the top that's like inside
the burger Xia Forge so that's actually
the walls I know what it looks like in
there I've seen the pictures so mm-hmm
so if you guys haven't seen the videos
about like the burgers before it just
looks kind of cool but it is still Forge
obviously giant closest I think they're
mighty made tank in there but this is
gonna be live for both of us so some of
this is gonna get read because I haven't
read it yet so you guys are gonna get a
live with us but but not the way it's
like so they said the fourth fortunes
are unlocked but not the way we intended
sometimes a Bungie we try new things
on many occasions in the past we've
enjoyed watching as the community work
together to try and solve puzzles
this was the idea behind the ob Labs as
the puzzle hunt started to drag on for
too long
Guardians watched from the sidelines
eager to afford some new weapons the
feedback was clear puzzles are fun but
now when they gate content you were
expecting a play or flexible enough to
change a plane when it's not playing out
as we had hoped and we decided to give
in you
owners access the burgers via forge so
it's open so they watched I mean they've
made these are some of the quickest
decisions they've ever made though like
when it came to the first towards they
lowered it down five levels in 48 hours
they did this one in I think it was
almost a little like 36 hours it was
less than that I think
I mean they've they've been much more
active in what they're doing
just as if feedback comes back to be
like hey this is totally wrong they're
pretty good to fix it so I mean what do
you I mean what do you think so far on
that yeah I think ultimately is a great
reaction they they they had to
understand that the thing was going on
too long it's preventing people from
going into the content so for them to
jump in and actually didn't have a
problem I thought that was actually the
right thing to do you know they try to
do something new they admitted it you
know and like I said the feedback was
clear puzzles of fun but with you not at
the as a gate content locker so that
part is cool you know again it's one of
the things lesson learned you know how
to do something like that moving forward
never lock onto that kind of deal so I'm
glad they jumped out in front of it just
unlocked it and again I just literally
thought this whole situation was
humorous I thought it was absolutely
hilarious then it happened so you know
again lesson learned
yeah so hopefully we don't have any more
like hey here's this new quest you gotta
go solve you know rocket science first
so that shouldn't happen in the future
or if it doesn't I still be to unlock
something later that's kind of cool as
opposed to what everybody expects so
surprises are fun a surprise that you
have to open like you know a 16 key lock
combination for not so fun
not so fun so they said naívi Labs are
still wind we solved some of the clues
in the labs puzzle are not as clear as
we intended our designers are looking
into this and we have a clarifying
update at 6 p.m. Pacific okay so
apparently that's gonna happen well that
would be now if you're interested in
helping solve it keep an eye so I'll try
at least and check on bungees Twitter
over there because that should be up as
of now so I guess I look yes sugar over
9000 not entirely sure what that means
for the holidays we mentioned some
sandbox changes oh here we go
you
definitely be talking about somebody say
sandbox sandbox that's Carol so we're
excited to shake things up a little bit
specifically how your most powerful
abilities spread destruction I'm glad
they said abilities because I don't want
them nerf and powerful weapons right now
because honestly like they feel really
good I don't want them mean like all
this that's too powerful you guys are
killing stuff too fast like don't touch
my thunder Lord it's too good it's
broken honestly but in a great way good
way we're excited to shake things up a
little bit specifically how your most
powerful said already ok so hello super
aficionados it's Dan G here to tell you
about upcoming changes to subclasses see
remember what we talked before
none of those changes it's about time I
do this in the 2.1 point for update you
will experience fresh changes to most of
the supers and a couple goodies here and
there for the subclasses at large if you
if you want just a quick take away
damage was increased for most supers so
we and slightly reduced for blade brush
and Nova warp mm kind of made it kind of
yeah blade brush kind of broken Nova
warp also broken TV people mm-hmm and
we've injected a couple new tricks into
some of the older subclass paths keep
reading for more detail that's I've been
waiting on this since forsaken launched
oh oh yeah we both got some skin in this
game Josh Hamrick recently touched on
our upcoming plans for the same sandbox
and we wanted to expand on our
intentions a bit further as frequently
as possible here are some the goals as
frequently as possible continue to shift
the combat meta with sandbox updates to
keep destiny fresh I feel like if they
have said this before but I've yet to
see them actually like follow through so
if they can actually make these changes
quicker than this is our sandbox patch
for the past like 2 or 3 months I still
feel like the sandbox patches have been
the absolute slowest thing every time
yeah it's all like that notorious though
like that's been the mo like
unfortunately the sandbox is always the
last to get changed or updated but at
least we getting is so kadhi what is it
investigates and improve outliers
underperformers in terms of popularity
and or effectiveness to keep all of your
sandbox options feeling relevant this is
probably the one for me is because as
soon as the new sub supers came out the
old one
suck like I mean in comparison but it's
like the new Sentinel claw subclass in
the middle tree and it just destroys the
other two and laying the chained void
grenades my brother walks around it just
throws one and you can clear a room as
playing a fire or the other night and he
was just using clear out the first room
of cero cheap by yourself with doom fing
pauldrons and that explosiveness it's
it's awesome but then you're like why
are the other two even there so yeah the
the underperformers needs some love an
address major quality of life sandbox
issues reported by the community to
maintain a smooth and consistent
gameplay experience well that sounds
pretty obvious
and this Pacifica update our goal is to
look at supers holistically across the
board bringing up damage where they
underperform fixing some major pain
points and adding new functionality so
which supers got a bump less Reese's
golden gun free shot and six-shooter
shadow shot mobius whoever arc staff
burning mall which is good
mmm hammer of saul code of the siege
breaker which I'm guessing is the non
hammer strike one mm-hm fist of havoc
sentinel shield nova bomb and daybreak
mmm small decrease play brush and okay
most of the old ones honestly yeah most
of but hold on I'm feeling a little bit
of way though um as a warlock I mean I
see Nova born Cataclysm and vote I got a
see you know what would they do with
that no doubt why alarm trans not on
there oh wait a minute I'm buggin yeah
that - yeah I'm like am i buggin am I
not seeing storm trades and sickle
fingers are still gonna be tickling we
stand like this we know what I feel like
that I don't know wait that one seems so
that was the obvious one right yeah that
one I mean I would have probably said
that burning mall I mean Golden Gun Ark
staff like those but like that one
should have been on the list and my at
least I'm gonna go there good yeah go
definitely three shot six you're gonna
need it we know that you know saying
this is cool I mean actually I can I can
it picking just warlock nitpicking
very surprised to see that they feel
that storm trances that occurred
yeah that's kind of a weird thing so
some point there's gonna be somebody
else can be like excuse me some
transfers all here what's happening so
some guy in the back of the room is
gonna raise their hand at some point so
I do like burning mall because that one
does feel while it's kind of fun no one
uses it like that's one of the most
under loop that's like the most
underutilized new one I think
um Nova bomb getting a boost up cuz I
mean some of the one in Dunn's just
can't keep up with something that can
just like pump out so much damage so
that'll be good I'll be curious some of
the tweaks they make so that'll be kind
of nice mm-hmm 'lord zeros like storm
trance clearly Opie working as intended
so this is beginning of a process we
believe we found a good place around
which to balance the subclasses this
means a few outliers will come down a
bit but most will be brought up it will
involve changes to super damage tuning
numbers on perks to make them more
effective will you find very the very
start of these changes if you don't see
a particular improvement you were hoping
for and know that there will be more to
come
please continue let us know what you
think well I guess we'll see so what do
we got hunter first Golden Gun six
shooter kills return a bullet oh that's
mean that's like your six-shooter and
PVE like if you can start killing a
whole bunch of stuff Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
like oh that's kind of fun dad actually
it's about duration
yeah duration and PvP would be based on
just makes perfect super region increase
I forget what that perk does that have
to look it out there with you so blade
brush the damage is now heavily weighted
on the delayed explosion instead of the
knife impact now deal self damage if the
knives explode too close yeah you can't
just have that like freakout moment and
blade brush me in a tiny hallway you're
gonna die too
yeah cuz I literally was playing PvP
today just like one random match like
going into what is the one on the tower
mmm yeah off get the damage I did the
tower when it's literally yeah it was
very far it's now but yeah banner fault
like in the back like back little baby
kind of hallway behind like point be
where the heavy was fun
back there picking up he's just like Oh
freak out bleh brush but yeah hopefully
actually he would die there so maybe fix
the bug where the knives would track
allies yeah I'd be kind of waste yeah
this Golden Gun change brings increased
uptime with your super for the way of
the outlier this means a skill based
mechanic to extend it for the way of the
Sharpshooter it's the ability to earn
your super more quickly I got two
differences so Golden Gun sounds kind of
sweet though
yeah go to gun looks good and you know
what it's an iconic clash of the zero to
che he's got crazy loves you don't say
skilled hunters only and dad dad I mean
let's be honest I mean it's kind of also
iconic with Kade right so it's just like
at least what I think about I think
about Kate a lot so to see that super
get some love is long overdue Golden Gun
hunters salute to you guys this sounds
really really cool I'm excited
mmm-hmm yeah should be pretty cool the
Night Stalker
so Moebius quiver entire damage bonus is
applied on the first hit instead of
stacking and multiplying increased
tether radius and life time made it
easier to fire successive tethers that's
all sounds good so I mean tethering
hopefully should be a bit more viable
always a good thing across the board
right and then we've got spectral blades
damage resistance and stealth is
decreased so hopefully you're a little
easier to kill if you're half invisible
duration is super while invisible
slightly decreased I mean it was busted
yeah even really broken with I forget
what exotic it is mmm-hmm I can't
remember my brother grounded too but
yeah there were people who would just
let go they do like a little quick like
dodge flip and they'd get more they're
super energy it was just it was really
really broken so I'm sure that will be
hopefully kind of brought in check this
one step 4 this is one step four shadow
shot and we intend to keep improving the
way it works for this past we focused on
Mobius quiver quality-of-life
arc straighter not one you see hardly at
all is now more heavily weighted toward
the heavy palm strike attacks back no
attack damage was reduced but much of
the added damage for the super went into
the heavy attack
lethal current bonus damage increased
thank you sound ways that's the question
I can never say go investigate
ARC's writer I mean I don't see him
often it has its kind of perks in places
but generally not one that I would say
is still looking like it got a ton but
we'll see how it goes
Titan we got sunbreaker part of my world
so Sun pots double the damage of the
burn on enemies finally kind of a use
length buff length increased from 3
seconds to 5 seconds now increases all
outgoing damage and itch Wow oh that's a
big debate output burning mall slam
radius increase slam fire tornado
improved homing clean mmm
have you ever actually used those things
in PvP I've been hit by him yeah I did
it before and I didn't even know what
trekked but if you could slamming half
curve it around the corner I swear yeah
pretty much
but just a slim radius increased I guess
they did crank up the damage too so all
of this combined I don't know if burning
Maul can actually be worthwhile to use
in like a PvE strike or something that
really pumps in damage oh yeah we'll see
but it's just it's it's got to be worth
the risk cuz I can throw hammers from
across the map do a lot of damage so if
I gotta be close enough to like send the
tornado up there a better hit hard
absolutely
Sentinel super damage is more heavily
weighted on heavy shield charge attack
no attack damage was reduced but much of
the added damage was for the super went
into the heavy attack so that's some of
the tweaks they're saying it's like they
did add damage but more to the super to
that big heavy attack not that bam bam
it's the striker terminal velocity there
are now three tiers of hang time the man
the amount of hang time for each tier
has been reworked each tier of hang time
now causes for for damaging shocks
instead of three the damage for hang
time bonuses has been increased and then
trampled which I don't even know off the
top of my head I probably should be nice
if I could look some of this up well
your defense we're doing this live yeah
we are doing at least zone time looking
at this swap no research is off top the
light shoulders light shoulder attacks
super cost has been reduced by
eighty-five definite lot that's a lot
damn oh is that just like the running
shoulder bait like it was running
shoulder charge sounds like it trampled
cannot be triggered every point
seconds up from everyone damn just like
that sounds rough
yeah or if you're running around killing
ads just enemy enemy enemy enemy and
just like you can kill a whole bunch ads
really quick just - and run everywhere
you'd be like Superman and um Man of
Steel fun image for co2 the Earth's a
shaker the changes the terminal Ozzy
should make it more engaging the first
year is now easier to achieve the second
tier you'll probably want some high
ground but if all you have is flatland a
directional slam near the peak of your
lift can proc it finally there's a new
third tier that will require some
serious height to activate on top of
that you'll need not only need to land
your hang time slams but also do it
quickly enough to get in all four paws
possible to maximize damage I didn't
actually didn't even notice I caught
that so each tier now causes for
damaging shocks instead of three so you
have four slams instead of three how do
you feel about this Titan I mean it's
like it's roaming supers are tough
they're like I mean as a warlock you're
roaming super as arc I mean how does
that really feel listen as far as D yeah
that's your roaming super yes just still
trash to me I mean I just it doesn't it
doesn't do enough damage and it's lookit
we'll get to warlock but but it's just
that risk of like being your super but
you have to run the whole way like
thunder strike I'll just like fly across
the map Robert your chaos reach you
coming home a halfway across the map so
I mean that stuff's just like quick fast
and like halfway away this stuff is I
mean you you get a cover ground and be
in there so this actually sounds pretty
cool code of the juggernaut if you play
it right you can ascend your super 4
minutes
mm-hmm I'm reading that right right
minutes
in PvE I know this sounds crazy but it
takes foresight and strategic choices
the light shoulder attack is almost a
movement mode with the new cheaper cost
with the increased mobility should be
able to lay some shoulder on bigger
targets and then get go on a run for
little guys to rebuild your super energy
that is okay that actually sounds crazy
as you can rebuild your super energy
okay yeah let's reread that o is what
he's saying but I'm trying to figure out
Co to the juggernaut we still
you play right that's all super games
more heavily no I'm gonna put look that
one up like that seems kind of insane
hold on yeah we got a we got research
that dad sounds crazy yeah I got a code
of a target hold on guys unprepared this
is live this is this is live feedback
right down all right come on top man
right off the top but yeah mm-hmm just
kinda change memorize your first things
here now you want to the code if you
play it right you extend your so you
can't see the code like which one's
what's tier no I think you guys gave me
see it yeah I don't know but potentially
that could be kind of amazing so look
forward to some fun with that it's
pretty much all I can say warlock all
right there we go it's like it's your
step I'm waiting all right dawn blade
changes all right super duration
increase that's a big one um I think I
think bottom tree warlock dawn blade is
not much a problem because um I believe
one of the perks that if you hit someone
with a door blade with the bottom tree
it would kind of kind of semi extend it
like chaos reach a little bit like long
as you keep getting kills with it but um
top tree warlock - this is actually
gonna benefit top tree but I'll be
honest I'm a little disappointed not
seeing you know I thought I would see
more with top tree door blade a little
disappointed here because that's the one
that you know plays on airplay and
jumping in the air and having inner
accuracy and getting abilities back so
to see nothing with that is yeah yes i
Chuck a fan he say yes barber tree and
it has homing yeah so for bottom tree
dawn blade this is gonna be nice but an
extending love but top tree yeah it's a
little buff but I was hoping let's get
into it
voidwalker changes Cataclysm increased
detonation
radius cluster damage increased improve
cluster bomb home and to make it more
consistent against single targets and
cluster bombs do longer detonate one
another this is a bigger things yeah
that's a big deal that's it cuz I died
honestly didn't feel kind of Quisling
was that much of a
I felt it was very powerful if use right
so that pretty much is Slava right now
what is is going to be a problem now I'm
just all I could think of an escalation
protocol right now so I'm excited you'll
explode yeah yeah so that we got vortex
okay linger damage increased slightly
okay
no vorb here we go slower movement while
charging fair enough fair enough I mean
you can kind of hunt people down but
don't worry warlocks we got a way to get
past that just uh it's just blinking
just jump just uh you'll be fine Oh
charging costs more energy and overall
duration is reduced now that's fair yeah
cuz I mean it didn't cost a lot and it
went too long that's the issue you use
in that Nova warp for as long you know
foot almost you kill a full six-pack and
then wait for someone to respond and
still have enough super if she kills
surviving so yeah damage resistance
reduced very slightly I hope so not too
much um PvP damage reduction okay charge
detonation will no longer be able to
one-shot another player in their super
Oh provided it has damage resistance
that's a big deal that's a big deal
right there
um charge that initial not be able to
one-shot wonder you know if you got your
super you're coming at me I can't
one-shot you with a charged Nova warp
you know provided that it has damage
resist dots that changes the game
because Nova what would be able to
compete and eliminate other supers so if
I'm reading this correctly does not have
damage if the super has damage
resistance like if you're not matched if
you're not running a void yeah then you
should should actually survive a shot
yeah and then a note summed up no ball
now just not just now chess now not just
for large groups the Bilbo changes above
Ross wall but we think together this
will help bring it down into a good
place a place similar to the supers that
we're raising up hold on strong Karla
here we go
Sage's store trains increased number of
targets appraisers here we go this but
this is what I'm talking about give me
something increased nuns like this is
like the tiniest thing for you to be
excited about that's a big deal
listen you tickle fingers out here this
is a big deal because if you're chaining
two or three I think maybe most you
could chain is to now if three you guys
are all in that you know sitting there
camping out with you whatever you're
doing what you Luna how and all that the
child running with it and I'll come by
that wall clamped up if y'all bunched up
that's a big deal
increased autonomous or was a big good
especially if you're running on what's
the helmet crowded tempest so get get
that going on all right so anyway well
my part of the table is super over
thanks reading okay he's excited to get
Eid yada he said this is the current
plan but things could change in the next
few weeks the official patch notes will
ship when the update is currently slated
for January 29th so we got what about
another week or two before we get into
that but uh yeah better I mean pretty
cool pretty cool just would like some
love for uh from you know from the
warlock standpoint far as the top um you
know don't blade tree would have been
nice you know I'm saying boy Walker I
was like wow they're really trying to
make that more sexy but I'm saying
that's cool and know what for as much
the super thing scares me a little bit
but everything else is fair play y'all
you know we that has to has to happen
but what you got matchmaking matches uh
yeah so next week we'll we will adjust
matchmaking settings in competitive this
probably is long long overdue
the change is scheduled to take effect
on January 15th 10:00 a.m. so that'll be
weekly reset weekly reset the world
systems team has been gathering feedback
and using it in conjunction with player
data to make the next change for how we
match opponents in the competitive
playlist we will be changing the
matchmaking parameters so that opponents
you finding competitive matchmaking will
be closer to your glory rank this is one
of those things I thought they already
did yeah
while the imbalanced match can still
happen we believe this change will
reduce the number of occurrences
dramatically players may experience
longer matchmaking times as will try to
ensure a good Gloria rank match before
opening up the search criteria thank you
so much for your feedback please keep it
coming
like this is one thing I feel like that
was mentioned before and now they're
just saying they're doing it now really
we read this already you know like
there's probably a flashpoint out there
were like okay yeah okay think of it be
it was already implemented at this point
so you know it again not I got a jump on
the imbalance match part I mean list I
got I got it
listen PC master-race I love y'all since
I've been here but we gotta talk about
this we have to talk about this because
you know I would say if I had to put a
ratio I'm in competitive a lot II I've
been playing a lot but actually playing
more competitive on PC because things
just feel so much better and I have to
say it's I would put a ranking about 60%
more than half of the matches I'm in
competitive I'm like it's some under man
foolishness going on and then you know
obviously we don't have the join in
option so listen I'm willing to wait in
in orbit you know for that fourth guy
I'm cool with that so you know if they
would they say that we're gonna
experience longer matchmaking times
that's cool but we've got it they've got
to get that going on they've got to get
this I feel like we like you said he we
keep talking about it so why isn't it
implemented no I mean that's why for me
I just always hear about matchmaking and
just so much in competitive like yeah
it's gonna be sweaty and maybe like not
forgotten seems so far to reach for me
to loon as hell if I actually put some
time in and really found a group maybe
just because like I hear like that up to
that glory rink but if you get above
like 3000 you may as well just like get
ready to sweat like it's gonna be crazy
so maybe this actually if it's finally
in effect which I'm glad I still haven't
done it yet because apparently it hasn't
been there so I don't know this is just
one thing I'm reading and I'm like I
swear we've talked about this before so
just
weird that they're saying it again so
maybe this will give me a reason to go
into competitive but I still don't have
much of a like PvP team on p pc so I
mean you know you get one or two more
your guys up we might be able to run but
yeah I I don't new the competitive that
much because PvE is my forte PvP I am
only okay mm-hmm mediocre at best and in
competitive I'm probably pretty terrible
actually so if this actually helps it
make it somewhat balanced that it's I
mean there should happen a long time ago
honestly that's competitive it's meant
to be a ranked playlist like I'm sorry
but if I step into competitive my glory
rank is like 25 there's no way in hell
Ocean City see anyone with a glory rank
lake I don't know 1000 2000 3000 that
shouldn't even be close exactly nah
would you oh wait you man so alright I
will say the DMR teams good cuz that
picture fire fire looks pretty good so
iron banner is coming back salad is
making use regular visit the tower next
week with iron banner first in 2019
he'll bring weapons and armor of course
as usual it's going to be control we
know all of that looks like we've got
submachine gun knows that we already had
heroes but I ain't giving us heroes bird
again that's what it looks like oh this
one looks new but that one looks like a
year old yeah it's like too bad oh my
god yeah yeah talking about that rank
good boy y'all like have you given us
heroes bird again back to back we should
have begun because before was hero's
burden and criminals dagger yeah yep or
now that that's literally what it is but
anyway yeah maybe they're just like you
guys really want the sniper
snipers to end like snipers outside of
whisper fur it's like boss damage
snipers have not had as much of an
appeal for me in general and does since
destiny to came out I agree just haven't
been there because they were stuck in
power for one even they switched over
it's it I can do I have more so much
more ammo with like my poles go figure
Scout still aren't that great so I mean
just it doesn't feel like snipers have
yeah much use in general I mean some
people are good in PvP and that's a
different animal and maybe this thing
has perfect perks for it but yeah
snipers still don't have that much
appeal for me but it looks cool at least
they still have to do something with
nitrous they still have to do something
it's it's still not in a good place it's
just just not I completely agree with
you mm-hmm
Siro says you rocks borealis all the
time yeah I mean there's exceptions to
the rule yeah there you go
stars borealis like for I mean soloing
nightfall borealis if you gotta go match
game it's perfect you can switch up you
got a decent man ammo can he hit hard
it's gonna pop whatever shield you're
looking at so I mean they have their
places and I was even mess around satara
gays just cuz was running something and
I was popping Captain Shields and
actually got the shield disorient
actually kind of worked so I mean they
have moments but in general it's nuts
it doesn't quite have the feel like d1
like whether it was ice breaker just
busting stuff up or they just don't
quite have it back yet so yeah uh where
are my keys
dude where's my car shredding guitar
shortly after the lunch of Destiny to
Dustin player support has been
monitoring reports describing
intermittent guitar errors in the final
encounter of last wish these errors have
been especially impactful players
attempting Petrus run that would piss me
off
I know it's why I haven't even tried
which Criers you know without any deaths
so after comprehensive investigation we
currently believe less with guitar
errors occur when players hit the limit
on the number of server controlled
objects within a single area this issue
is exacerbated during the final
encounter and last wish when when
encounter specific objects are left over
from the Riven fight reaching this limit
caused the server to crash our teams are
working to identify the root cause that
yeah so I guess pick up all your I don't
know it seems we're just like pick up
everything on the ground you can but it
still seems very odd yeah alright Forge
stuff we've got obsidian accelerator
which I definitely don't have any of
those yet we're just investigating issue
worthy obsidian accelerator in which the
item is discarded when players hit the
use button that sucks that's uh players
should turn this item into 801 instead
of oh yes okay so that's like an item
that will it like goes into
the black black armory weapons but you
have to like take it to her to get the
up the actual version you put in just
again another reason to go back to you
know why are we going back to her weapon
it's again an onion just like it's not
just used to get rid of it it's like
okay use that and put in the weapon just
yeah I'm gonna step
I'm whenever it's coating because it
seems like everything almost every
aspect involving her it has a step to go
back to her like to yeah to register
something but whatever deep as the
traffic drives by traffic goes by well
Wow
key mold and mysterious box where movie
asking players reports that the black
armory key mold which I did yet but I've
been touched yet becoming available
first character only becoming available
on the first character its received I
haven't even touched my other character
but I'm really not looking forward to
that and I don't know which character I
picked it up on but I guess I might be
limited if it does forge key issues
master Smiths triumph doesn't count rare
research framed blame an arc poison
arrow perk we're investing poison arrow
personal a monarch exotic bow are is
inconsistent over long distances I could
actually see that honestly because I've
messed with that bow and my bows that
usually uses sniper so yeah kind of
actually wonder I mean I'm not a perfect
shot because it's got to be in that
little perfect zone for the poison
explosion but yeah that's kind of a
thing for jinafire can't be claimed
after players complete their fortune
fire badge yeah they got some issues
with black armory and like weapon frames
how much how many weapon frames have you
really done oh I'm one frame to all
right now okay
oh yeah so I asked you a question
because um not I've been playing I'm
actually playing black armory now like I
literally and starting to play now like
do those frames for her rotate you know
I so is that a reset thing yeah it's a
weekly reset so now rotate once a week
the powerful frames right now the
question I have last question having a
problem if I have one to unlock now does
do I lose that ability do i you have to
use it on the week that's a quarter so
if you have the bounty in your inventory
mmm-hmm that will carry over but if you
click on the bounty and then you have
the ballistic slugs in your inventory
that won't carry over gotcha okay so
pretty much they're limiting you to two
a week because there's
three of them you can pick from mm-hmm
now the only problem I've had with that
say I'm taking my Titan through the
Izanami Forge mm-hmm okay so I do the
powerful weapon frame and I'll get to
that in a second zero so I go through
the Izanami quest line then you for each
for each Forge when you unlock it you do
one specific weapon so in that one it's
the bow well that counts as one of your
powerful weapon frames and then if I use
one of those ballistics logs for another
powerful weapon frame that's it that's
my two so if you're unlocking forges
even though there's two weekly bounties
you could get screwed out of one of them
so that's one of those things to keep in
mind as well
no fair enough no I'm glad you listen
I'm I'm actually enjoying the content
not I've unlocked it and I've had I'm at
the power level to to do it you know
kind of thing you know and again we just
couple of missteps here in there with
the way certain things been handled and
I just want a little bit more complexity
but moving forward we have to see if
this if they stick with this annual pass
structure I'm very curious about that
was that something that was implemented
by Activision as a compromise for them
to continue to bring out content we're
gonna learn a lot man
we really we're gonna learn lies I'm
very curious move forward how to sting
goes did you a question about the
augment yup so I was just letting your
ramp up so augmented weapons you guys
will see those at a de instill the
powerful weapon frames those will drop
it like you know powerful gear bounty
level so those will be for that
augmented weapons will take what I'm
specifically I did today
it's a powerful or it's a augmented
weapon frame for dreaming city and
you'll go do things in the dreaming city
like three public events or three law
sectors when you then have that frame
you take it to the forge and then you
actually kind of unlock the frame you
can click on it and get the gun hmm what
it will do is drop a weapon that has an
extra perk option on it so take a normal
weapon for example like my Duke or that
one's bad because the perks are weird a
normal Tiger spite you're gonna get you
know your barrels
you'll get your magazine options say
or something like that and then you have
your two perks mm-hmm but they're stuck
now if you do an Augmented weapon that
first perk tree is gonna have two
options on it so in a sense you could
have I'm trying to think what can fall
in that department like kill clip and
rampage for example I don't know so you
could have the option of both lucky
enough like an absolute god role like
right good good you know or no it would
be outlaw or say like outlaw and feeding
frenzy I think that's what would fall
there and maybe you could have both or
something like that you basically you'll
get two options in that first perk role
and then the second one is set so it'd
be nice augmented weapons kind of had
both so like if you're going for a
random role on a dreaming city weapon
you can you could have two options like
for each part but it's I mean there
wants to be like hey I'm looking for
just a good Tiger spite auto rifle auto
rifle you know pickup the Dreaming City
augmented bounty do that see even get a
roll because those are usually going to
be specific to those areas there's a
dreaming city one there's usually one
related uh Vanguard weapons I'm sure
there's probably a crucible one so
you're gonna have different weapon pools
they each augment it can pull each
augmented weapon frame can pull from and
so you can kind of pick and choose what
you're trying to grind for don't it
gives you an option for stuff like that
but yeah it's been a busy week
20:19 is off to a crazy start indeed
yesterday should we shared with you some
news about the future of Bundy Bundy
Al Bundy did words alright guys don't
expect these changes behind the scenes
to impact our plans for destiny or the
current rollout of content calendar iron
banner starts next week a quest to earn
a story to hand cannons coming up I'm
super ready for the sub class changes
that come along with it so that'll all
be on the 29th so when that comes yet
the past changes sandbox all that
stuff's coming and thank you for going
on this journey with us so that is
that's the club so nothing too crazy in
there they're not giving it like spill
the beans on all the business stuff
that's just not gonna happen so sohow
except for word man like how do you know
how do you feel we've digested the
information you know we've got the state
of you know bungees official statement
we've heard Activision statement you
know um how you feeling
moving forward and more importantly
destiny three like wait where's your
head at with this oh I mean the rumors
we heard of more RPG type stuff maybe
that was a clash of like hey this is
where we want to take it we think this
is what our audience is gonna want
Activision's like no let's not do that
that kind of narrows your player base
and that's maybe that was like a
clashing point and maybe it's not even
destiny 3 maybe it's called something
else I mean honestly I don't know on
like what is to come
I am excited as to that there are little
teases we get of things like a healing
grenade from warlock mm-hmm The Sentinel
shield like walking around being
basically just a tyent giant tank
there's little pieces as you watch some
of the footage that's trickling out
about anthem of when you truly have
classes right like they have like the
Colossus that's your big hunk of junk a
tank I mean that's your big boy with a
giant shield who's gonna like taunt and
take like aggro and damage and just be
smote it like and gonna be able to take
it and then you've got like your little
you know nimble interceptor who's gonna
run around to do those little pieces so
those are like the classes of an RPG
that I still kind of miss and that's one
thing I've asked even like eons ago just
like one of those wishes I I wish we
could have more and this comes back to
like stats on our characters and things
like that and there's even one when I
was looking at like the mods I was like
please just get us some numbers cuz if I
just like throw it says like you know
magazine mod it's like says an up arrow
cool is it gonna give me one or two
little things like that which I feel
things like you know division and anthem
that stuff is coming and those are gonna
have their RPG pretty deep elements and
I think some of those things are what
people some of us enjoy and if you don't
have to dive in too deep you may not
have to worry about it you know if you
still pick up a good gun and you're like
hey this is cool
but if somebody wants to go like full
min/max mode it's kind of hard to do
that investme no I agree
I agree and that's it being that excites
me a little bit because you know shouts
to zero he's always said bonuses
absolutely um you know is one of them
things that you just say okay
forsaking is their vision and what they
co-signed you know I mean now do we get
that hard core you know do we do we get
that the mid maxing do we get that that
that real deep intrinsic metagame that
you know we were still being able to you
know really isolate certain aspects of
the game armor you know I mean like you
said stat pieces like things like that
too with things that kind of the
division and stuff does very well you
know it's very interesting that this
change is happening now and um just to
see because we all know the competition
is thick right so I had to be money to
chat he said yeah he wants to see more
RPG elements have effect on classes and
really define classes yeah he's right I
totally agree with what were you and he
is saying because it's like does them
does Bungie being free from Activision
allow them to truly give us those
hardcore MMO sensibilities right do we
get that level because no that was that
the thing with D to Wendy to launch it
was that you know we felt the over
casualization and some would say the
Activision effect right that was driving
people crazy that you know the hardcore
were pissed off so there's this current
you know there's always that shift
between the hardcore and and the casual
and definitely you know you know these
guys are psychos they want to get as
many people in there but let's just say
now destiny doesn't become that game it
becomes the hardcore game maybe you know
then we got we got to talk about the
model right what happens with the motto
another question I got for you what
about a possibility I know this may
sound scary to sell but uh free to play
I don't know if they can do that
honestly I don't know this game is built
for that at least I mean it doesn't feel
that way it's like the you don't just
have like one map that you're making
some tweaks on like a fortnight where
you just really skin after skin after
cosmetic and then stuffs just like stuff
you can purchase I mean they've got to
put time into rendering in like new
worlds and areas and planets and go
like I don't think the free-to-play
piece works quite as well in this model
just because of what it takes to do this
and on the other side what do you think
about a subscription like completely
flipped looks ruling I know I know it is
interesting because this many routes
this can go and I'm dying I do think my
gut tells me they are not gonna get in
bed but anyway let's shout out to my
xbox guys you know I'm saying I know
they saw the tweet you know Phil's fetch
the minute it was like you know what it
felt like it felt like you got like two
people going out you ready break up and
did like the video that you find out the
chick is single like Phil pulled up in
so hey that's how you doing like Joey
and friends how you doing you know you
know you valued over here we can't wait
to see what you do it's surprisingly
Bungie was receptive I'm not gonna look
more into this you know big but it was
just funny how quick that was and we
obviously know the relationship we
obviously know Microsoft is in a
completely different place but I do
think and it's gonna piss my xbox guys
off I don't think it's beneficial for
them honestly to go back to that kind of
a structure I think it's probably best
for them to stay multiplayer you know
saying and unless there's some
ridiculous deal but I still can't I
still can't see a scenario where they
accept any deal that gives destined kind
of exclusivity you know I'm saying so I
think I think the exclusive error is
done that's my gut that's my prediction
that's what I'm rolling with you know
I'm saying and we'll see what happens
man we've got Chad got some great
questions right now but what do you
think and then we jump into chat of like
what just like subscription or oh as far
as now besides the subscription thing do
you think they remain independent or
because I think that was the whole goal
yeah I mean I don't think they're just
gonna be like hey we'll do this now
where they go for distribution do they
like pull PC and eventually transfer in
the API all their day-to-day they move
that stuff off a battlenet do they move
it over to at
do they go to steam I mean those are
sides of PC you're stuck in an Xbox and
PlayStation it's like Bungie still works
with them so I mean some of those deals
and things may or may not be there they
may not have like the same promotion at
e3 but I mean honestly d30 seems like
that's kind of like is it on PlayStation
stage now
maybe not see now this is what I could
make now you getting into what I was
going see what I predict is they stay
independent
but like see zeros question is like do
you think he said let's say dusty threes
hype is building they toss Xbox and into
game pad I mean d2 in a game pass I can
see scenarios like that where they say
you've got the marketing deal right
whereas they're not gonna do exclusive
con for content but kind of like ant-man
Adams not doing exclusive content when
they would debut on the Xbox age right
it was just that you know Microsoft had
the ability to present it first right
and same thing with division like you
know there was an exclusive content on
division that that Xbox had their
PlayStation didn't have but it was
associated with the marketing rights so
I'm very curious if anything exercise a
chance is that but I think I agree be
money I think they need to go anywhere
they can I think that we'll probably see
it outside of them like Steam or
possibly epic but you see how aggressive
epic has been lately you know especially
with epic taking the division right now
that's a big deal um I see them trying
to be as much place and don't underrate
the Adsense situation would be with the
mobile that's a big deal to and I'm very
curious to see what happens there as
well
so what Adsense what's that says without
it Nettie's Nettie's like that's google
adsense well you're correct
Betty's like I'm very curious about what
happens you know I'm saying because they
are an investor you don't listen they
there's no B they dropped a hundred
million in there so there's definitely
some they have some major skin in the
game I mean whether that was the thing
that pushed him over to be like hey we
can't have some freedom with this with
an
like hey we're gonna take its wind like
you know ten percent stake in the
company but you guys can take this to
invest and start growing and then they
have that on their back in for profits
and stuff like that I mean that could
have been just a negotiation for them to
be like hey where can we get our freedom
okay Nettie's has a gazillion dollars
can we get some of it like I mean that
could have been just part of that to
help them get their freedom have a small
stake but probably not much of a say
because you know Nettie's may you know
be like hey you guys have some good
content let's get behind them and that
was just investment they chose to make
so in my mind's eye I mean but it's like
can you go steam and I mean epic games
lunch or can you put it be really
hilarious to see like hey would you like
featured games and it's like steams
launcher or but it's like out an epic
and you like division to go to the next
page destiny to and so like that's weird
yeah really really odd so I could see
exclusivity I could see you know if epic
or one of those guys aggressive in China
you know backup some which would benefit
Bungie right because now I playing these
guys they they clearly are hitting off
Ubisoft with some cash to be able to get
that level exclusive to so I'm if they
pulled them off steam it's definitely
something but also for lunch you mean
they've got a lookout if you go to epic
it's like you're just getting more bang
for your buck I mean people like
fortnight's everywhere so most people
have it anyway and it's just like it's
another launcher it's just battle that's
the same thing it's just a way to launch
the game and if Bungie gets more money
and they're in the pin and then they can
take the money then it's wrong with that
yeah this it's all interesting but the
future is interesting and but it's
exciting we get we get to see what
happens we get to see what happens to
this game that we love you know they've
got their dependence independence now
free at last free at last you can do it
you can do your MLK speech now but you
know at the same time there's a lot of
responsibility to that and that dad I
want to see how to handle that how to
content drops how the monetization all
that good stuff and also the exclusivity
how they handle that aspect as well so
you know hopefully come September or
next comet expansion we will get more
clarity and I'm very curious to see
at that point do all the PlayStation
exclusives kind of like revert back at
that moment you know
so it's interesting it's interesting
yeah this is really exciting stuff yeah
I mean even zeros and chad is asking
about like the warframe route I mean
they're totally free to play and they
get their you know funds and if earth I
mean they've they've they have to have
been like evaluating business models see
what works see what can work for them
testing stuff over time and I mean is
ever verse gonna be a thing and chief is
asking about of mobile destiny I don't
think that's gonna happen well I think
Nettie's is more of like an investor not
trying to get destiny on a phone but
they have they have a very background in
that route and I want it I want to got a
shout out a Matt piscatella from PD he
had a put at we said everyone
celebrating and he said you know I get
it
he said but you know their investor they
have those option they're gonna want
certain options now it may not be maybe
it's not destiny maybe it's another game
that bungees working on or maybe some
mobilized version or something you know
in that effect that could be different
or being like a companion I don't know
but that they have they have a
foundation based in mobile gaming
Adsense aka and Eddie's yeah I mean just
so much stuff is up in the air I really
it's like there's normals more questions
than answers at this all I know how to
like catch up plague we're just gonna
have to wait and see so far bungees
still gonna give us the content they're
promised so I mean if you got you're in
your past that's not changing I mean the
annual pass is definitely gonna be an
interesting year for them to learn and
see if this is what they stick with if
they're gonna have all these changes of
what's to come
I mean this may have been there playing
with Activision behind them for the next
few years but going into the future I
mean this may be a completely different
business plane now so I'm along for the
ride as you guys know it were crazy
destiny fans so we'll be here for the
journey but where it goes and your guess
is as good as mine yeah absolutely
absolutely yeah I was like I don't know
why I feel like this thing was gonna be
longer we do this every time we feel
when I have a zillion things we're
talking about we're done in like an hour
and a half we have like three topics and
we go off like on a crazy tangents and
two hours later we're like we we need to
work on wrapping this thing up
so this one much longer but yeah we got
we got most of it out but uh yeah
so hopefully the new name sticks
hopefully you guys like it we will work
on you know kind of finalizing some
graphics I just threw something up today
just so we could have something for you
guys to look at
but yeah Bungie will continue doing
their things we've got patches coming up
in a couple weeks a little bit of you
know matchmaking coming up next week
Shadow Thrones out there guys have fun
in that one the new forge may be the
puzzle get solved maybe it won't we'll
see at some point if they finally drop a
hint like a month later be like all
right seriously guys yeah as well as I
wonder when it's actually gonna get
solved like what's your over-under like
at this point cuz I don't know people
have just given up oh I probably say
like another week I mean what's that
what did your Android friend um did he
figure it out yet the one that's not
human the t1000 Derek no no not yet I
think he's just like kind of been
putting up videos like showing what goes
so far but I don't think he's figured it
out yet yeah I mean I think giving the
community a little bit more time I think
you know maybe another I would say like
a week or two I say a week I get it done
but I just want to know if you solve it
what happens like what is the reward for
that I'm dying to know that it's like I
thought it was just like you know shader
and Sparrow or ghost or something like
that from some tweet somewhere I thought
I saw that so if that really is all it
is and there's no other hidden opening
nothing and I'm probably gonna be pretty
disappointed yeah that's what that's one
thing you would hope so I get a mistake
lesson learned do not lock content you
know saying behind some crab solutely
puzzle I don't don't do that
I'm saying definitely don't do that so
we shall see how they go forward with
this stuff going but I I do like the
idea I like the concept just the
execution me well I guess we'll wrap
this one up so you guys have been with
us we haven't made it too
50 or like 52 yet for a full year but
you know a couple weeks off in the
middle but yeah podcast number 45 still
it's Yvonne Tess and Lord kognito coming
at you guys with the talk of the world
of destiny but I can tell you xx start
of 2019 was a happier place for dusting
than the start of 2018 that's all that's
easy to say is one of all if we if you
if you look at the tapes you go back to
when we started at this time which is
around this time and what the stated act
this game was compared to now this
almost this euphoric optimism oh man
it's night and day and it's good man
it's good because like I said you see
what's coming we know we've got some
good games come in that we might also
wouldn't have the last word on which is
anthem division we want to know what's
going on with those titles and stuff
like that and to see you know this kind
of announcement happened all in the
midst of that this is gonna be a very
good year I think for this genre of game
you know a lot of competition is always
good you know it always brings out the
best and I'm now super excited just to
see Bungie do things in their own vision
their own way so to me that that's dope
well yeah it's gonna be awesome and on
another note 23 minutes ago Niobe labs
was actually solved oh so so apparently
there was like some piece or some
scripts that was missing somewhere so I
threw it up on their Twitter and that
was about an hour ago and I guess they
said it was solved so as some piece that
I guess was just needed to be finally
put out there so yep that is finally
solved so I guess will look out for the
YouTube videos explaining all the stuff
that happens cuz I'm sure somebody's
gonna have it up in about 12 hours so
all of that stuff will be there but yeah
I think for me you guys know where to
find me it's twitch and twitter if you
guys are watching me live it see bonta's
everywhere youtube if you haven't
followed me there for me I'm probably
gonna be working on a solo corrupted
nightfall and then probably gonna try
and dabble into bashing my head against
the solo flawless shattered throne so if
you guys are on twitch right now just
look for those notifications when I go
back live doing that I'd actually dare
that's good
well I was like the the nightfall may
happen an eyeshadow thrown swell we're
gonna be tomorrow after my day kind of
calms down so my morning's a little
crazy but yeah tomorrow afternoon
yeah probably that so you guys know
where to find me and see Montes the
follows have been amazing by the way
they are everybody out you got me yes
gonna say all right 30,000 subs on my
youtube channel and still go and so I
can't thank everyone all of you out
there have been awesome and like
honestly I wish I could just send every
30,000 those over to iron Lord podcasts
cuz they they haven't listened to you
guys yet they do deserve just as many
out there so if you guys are in my
twitch please jump over find iron Lords
podcast YouTube channel or just looking
up on iTunes anything it's worth it's
worth to listen every time I promise is
making much appreciate and Congrats to
success man I mean again it just keeps
on rolling and you just getting bigger
and bigger and more it's funny to see my
community you've become a staple in my
community I'm seeing people like pull up
your video and they like like I'd been
owing to me like I'm just like creeping
in the background and I'm like you're
becoming the de facto guy like dad's
dope shoutout Chris cover and um it's
just good to see it like I said man I
the talent the minute I met him I was
like the minute I met this guy it's it's
it's there the passion is there and he
keeps doing it man so he is the artiste
the effectually
Bob Ross of Destiny the perfection is
the soloist I wear some graphic person
is gonna draw me if they ever find me
with like a basically like paint palette
in my hand a screen a screen behind me
or something at school afro with the
perm oh my god beautiful got to be the
worst thing that could ever happen yeah
it's not belong in an afro doesn't
matter I'm as white as it gets dude no I
can't pull off an afro my hair is just
gonna know it'll be a hilarious picture
that when that happens but yeah stay
tuned guys we'll keep the content coming
to you guys we are back we'll be doing
this pretty much every week that were in
town
Guardian it is the year of Guardian con
it's also the year of Marvel's crazy
movies
we have Guardian Con July if you guys
are going to that hit us up on Twitter
when it gets closer cuz you know keep an
eye out if you're really close
chaos ruler is asking about 30,000 face
reveal so not 30,000 face reveal I have
a very specific plan for when now it's
gonna help so stay tuned
that will happen I've got my green
screen already so it's gonna happen you
guys just have to have to stay tuned
it'll be it'll be a little while but I
have a very certain time that that's
gonna happen for me you already know
what it is more kognito on twitter all
that good stuff thanks for the love from
me bounces man iron law podcast on
YouTube all your social medias all that
good stuff
big big episode this Sunday man and
hopefully have something nice plan on my
boy maka he mocking 91 productions
should be in the building so um he's
this guy is one of the best achievement
hunters trophy hunters a great fantastic
guides I've known for a long time so
he's going to be in the realm of the
Lord's at his Sunday night law podcast
at 1:00 p.m. Eastern also state watch
that episode because we might have a
special guest make a cameo in
conjunction with maka um at least for
one topic and that might be the destiny
topic someone that has a lot of
knowledge on the going ons in that area
so fingers crossed if that special guys
can make it so definitely tune in for
that if you're very interested on
certain aspects of the whole Bungie
Activision thing more stuff that we even
discussed here guys even a little bit
more knowledgeable than us so that would
be cool far far more than a little bit
more knowledgeable I'm guessing the
flashpoint loyalists that contingent we
see you in here rapid I'm saying and
getting used to the new name and
everything like that and we're glad that
you like it and stuff like that I'm just
gonna move forward man we see how this
thing goes man but thank you guys for
the support to see you guys at this time
and starting late because of the table
really appreciate it man
both chats really cool a lot of love and
we love doing this thing for you guys
man so appreciation is there alright
well and on that note that's all I got
so we will see you guys next week and
I'm out have an awesome week weekend
wherever wherever you guys are at have a
good one you too peace